[Music]  in recent years europe has experienced  challenges but challenges can be turned  into opportunities  if europeans face them together  [Music]  the eu is contributing to a brighter  future  a future that tackles climate change and  helps protect our planet  invest in young people research and  innovation  a future that makes your health systems  in europe have the means to face crises  [Music]  the european union which began more than  70 years ago with robert schuman  is your union today  we invite you to take part in shaping it  the future is in your hands make your  voice heard during the conference on the  future of europe where people will  discuss their hopes and ideas for a  stronger eu  you